The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
INSTRUCTOR: So today, we
start on project 4, which is,
as you know, the big project.
And Helen is going to do a
walkthrough of the project,
and the code, and
the organization,
because this is a pretty
big sized project.
It's got about
4,500 lines of code.
And it's not code that is
kind of like simple code.
It's all content-bearing code.
So I think having a bit
of an orientation to it,
more than we give for the
other codes that you work,
on which are pretty
small, this will be great.
So, Helen, take it away.
HELEN XU: Hi, everyone.
Can you hear me?
Awesome, so today we're going
to be doing the walkthrough
for the final project.
You can look at the code
and clone it publicly here.
And please remember to fill up
your team's by 7:00 PM today,
so we can populate the
list and get your repos.
Yeah, and if there are
any issues accessing this,
just let me know.
Or put it on Piazza
and then we can fix it.
So we just had a
game of Lesierchess.
But in case you
missed it, we'll go
into more details about
what the game actually does.
So first, we're going to
go through the game rules.
So you saw that there
are these pieces.
There's these triangles.
And there's kings.
So the triangles are pawns.
And the kings, they
look like crowns.
And there are two teams.
There's orange and lavender,
or tangerine and lavender.
And each side starts out with
seven pawns and one king.
And this is the
starting position.
So you can see like the
kings are in the corner.
And they're just lined
up like in the middle.
And each piece has
four orientations.
So you can see that the pawn
is up, down, left, right.
And then the king
is also like that.
And in general, the game starts
with tangerine moving first.
And then the play alternates
between the two players.
Each piece moves the same,
whether it's king or pawn.
And each turn has two parts.
So you saw the demo.
But you move first.
When you pick one of your
pieces, and you move first.
And then at the end, your
King has to fire the laser.
And the laser reflects off
the long edge of the pawn.
And they'll kill the pawn if
it shoots the short edges.
And one side wins when
the king gets shot,
or when the opposing king gets
shot, whether by themselves
or by your own king.
And so I talked a
little about moving.
And at the beginning of each
turn, the player to move
chooses a piece to move.
And you can move your
King or any of your pawns.
And there are two
types of moves.
There's basic moves,
and swat moves.
And basic moves are just,
basically, shifts or rotations.
So in the example, you can
rotate 90, 180, or 270 degrees.
So in the top, row
you just rotate.
This is the example
of moving a pawn.
So you rotate your pawn.
Or you can move to an
empty adjacent square.
So those are the
bottom two rows.
And there are eight adjacent
squares in this example.
So there are eight shifts.
But there would
be less than eight
if you were, for example,
like at the edge of the board.
And on a move, you can
either shift or rotate.
But you can't do both.
There are also these swap loops.
So if you're adjacent
to an opposing piece,
you can switch with them.
And then you have to
make another basic move
after that, that is not a swap.
So, basically, you can either--
and it has to be
with that same piece
that you just swapped with.
So you just either
shift or rotate.
Is everyone good on the rules?
Just a couple more things.
So there's this
Ko rule, which is
from Go, which ensures that
the game makes progress.
So it makes a move illegal if
it undoes the opponent's most
recent move by just moving
back to where you just were.
So this is an example.
Let's say you're tangerine.
And you swapped with the
purple one right next to you.
And then you shifted
left and bottom.
And so lavender can
return by swapping back
with your orange piece,
and shifting again.
But this is actually,
illegal because now
you just got to your
original position.
So you're not allowed to just
keep cycling back and forth.
And so a draw occurs if there
have been 50 moves by each side
without a pawn being
zapped, the same position
repeats itself by
the side on move,
or the two players
agree to a draw.
So just kind of like
in chess, a chess clock
limits the amount of time the
players have to make a move.
So you can't just keep
competing indefinitely.
When it's your moves,
your clock counts down.
When it's your opponent's
moves, your clock stops.
So it's not counting your time.
And we used Fisher time control.
There's a picture
of Bobby Fisher, who
made it, up which used an
initial time budget and a time
increment.
So in this example,
there's fis60 and 0.5,
which means that,
in the beginning,
each player has 60 seconds.
And you get to use the 60
seconds however you want.
And when you end your move,
you get 0.5 extra seconds.
But the 60 and 0.5
could be anything.
That's just an example.
So we'll go into an
example of how you actually
play this game.
For a king to zap
the enemy king,
it risks opening itself
to counter-attack.
So look at this example.
And how can tangerine zap
the lavender pawn in F5,
by moving one of its pieces?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: Move C4.
AUDIENCE: Tangerine,
that's lavender.
HELEN XU: You're
tangerine in this example.
And you're trying to
zap the one on F5.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: You move the
tangerine piece at E22 to F1.
HELEN XU: E2 to F1.
Oh, sorry, by zap, it
means shoot the backside.
That would shoot the long side.
Good point.
Yeah, so you're trying
to kill the piece on F5.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: Yeah, exactly.
So in this, you can move
C2 to B1, as you just said.
And then you draw the path.
And you can see that
you've just killed--
or if you're tangerine, you've
just killed the piece at F5.
Now, how can lavender counter?
By counter, we mean
lavender can win
the game from this position.
AUDIENCE: Is it A4 to A3?
HELEN XU: A4 to A3.
No, I don't think so.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: Sorry, what?
King, like the orange one?
Oh, the lavender one.
You're trying to
shoot the orange king.
Oh, yes, you're right.
You can, actually.
Yes, good, that's not
the one that we had,
but apparently
there are two ways.
Good.
So if you notice
you could also--
that's another way
to get that path.
But you can also move
one of the pawns.
Cool, so this is
just pointing out
one of the subtleties of
the game, which is you
should watch out for
just naively killing
all the pieces you can,
because that might open you up
to the opponent.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: Yes, it can
be from any direction.
But the pawns only
die if you shoot them
from not on the long edge.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: What if you
shoot your own block?
HELEN XU: By block,
you mean your own pawn?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HELEN XU: You'll die.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
HELEN XU: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: Yes, but only one
piece can be on each square.
But you can have
as many near you.
But do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Can you make it
impossible to kill your person?
HELEN XU: Like your King?
Like if you barricaded
it by pawns.
But then the opponent can
come in and swap with them,
so it will open your barricade.
AUDIENCE: Can the purple
king shoot upward?
HELEN XU: If it wanted to.
But then in this example, it
would shoot up off the board,
and nothing would happen.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you kill
a pawn, does the laser
stop at the place where
the pawn is or does it
go through the pawn?
HELEN XU: No, it
just shoots one.
Good questions.
Everyone good so far?
OK, great.
PROFESSOR: This year,
it shoots only one.
Last year, it kept shooting.
AUDIENCE: Can the
king shoot itself?
HELEN XU: Yes.
It should try not
to, but it can.
So you should be careful.
So moving on-- we use force
Fosythe-Edwards Notation,
which is a representation of a
chess position using a string.
So you can see an example
of the starting position.
And the bottom
includes the string
that describes the
starting position.
If you look at the
representation,
the arrow corresponds
to one of the rows.
And that points to the substring
that has a bubble over it.
So in this row, there is
one purple pawn at B3,
and two orange
ones at F3 and G3.
So this is row three.
And the slashes separate
the rows in the string.
And the one represents
there's an empty space.
And then there's a
pawn facing southeast.
And then there's three
empty spaces, and one facing
northwest, and then one
facing southeast, and then
an empty space.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: Oh, yeah,
it's animated.
What do you mean?
Yeah, so at the end of the
string, there's also a--
it just tells you which
side's move it is.
So this is the opening position.
But you can use any
position in this notation.
And this is useful
for debugging,
because if you, for example,
you're running a bot,
and it crashes at some position.
And you can get back
to that position.
You can start up
the game and just
go there without having to make
all the moves to get there.
And this is how you
represent the games.
So each of these is one move.
And the left column
is tangerine.
And the right
column is lavender.
And an example,
you can see E6, E7,
means they moved a
piece from E6 to E7.
B3L, so you rotated
the piece on B3 left.
There's D5, E4, F5, which
means that you swapped.
So your original
piece was on D5.
You swapped with the one at E4.
And now you moved
that piece to F5.
So the one that was
E4 is now on F5.
And the opposing piece is now
on D5, because you swapped.
You can swap and then rotate.
So instead of just
having a third square,
you would just have a rotation.
And at the end, you
could see who won.
So in this one, lavender
one because it's 0-1.
But 1-0 would mean
tangerine wins.
And half and half
would be a draw.
So you can look at the
logs for your games.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: There's a
rotate up and rotate down.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
do a U-turn?
HELEN XU: Oh, is that what U is?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, U-turn.
HELEN XU: Oh I, see because
there's only three rotations.
Yes, sorry, so left is 90.
Then right is 270.
And U is 180,
because you flip it.
Is everyone good
on the notation?
This is just how you
describe the games,
if you wanted to
look at your logs,
and if there are some issues.
So you can test your bot with
other teams in the class,
as well as with staff bots
on the scrimmage server.
And we have a reference,
which is here, which
is just the additional release.
But we will be optimizing
our bots while we're
optimizing your bots.
And we'll release a reference
plus, and maybe an even better
one later, which you can play
with on the scrimmage sever.
So I'll just do a
really quick demo.
So right now, since we haven't
done the team formation yet,
you are not able
to log into this.
But once you do your
team formation, probably
by tomorrow, you'll
be able to log in.
And, basically, you can see
the general functionality.
So this updates your
player, pulls your player
from your repo, whatever's
on the master branch.
And then right now,
there's only reference,
and reference plus,
and reference TAs.
And here's a team
with me and Jess.
But later on, we'll
populate this list
with everyone in the class.
And then you can
challenge anybody else
in the class to see how you do.
You can also challenge us.
So you would just
pick, for example,
let's say I wanted to
challenge reference.
And then a hit send challenge.
Now, you can see that there's
some new matches spawned.
And this is how I look at all
the matches that I've played.
So each time you
hit send challenge,
it spawns off two games,
one where you're tangerine,
and one you're lavender.
So that's how you can watch
the matches on the scrimmage
server.
Everyone good?
I'm going to move on so
don't run out of town.
You can watch them later.
And you can even play your own.
OK.
And, in addition to
the scrimmage server--
so the scrimmage
server, you can only
spawn off one game at a time.
But you can do more.
And you don't have
to necessarily do it
on your master branch,
or against opposing teams
in the class.
So there's something called the
Cloud autotester, which you can
run by going to your Athena.
And then you type
in this command.
You do autotest run.
And then you do
the time control.
And you give it a number of
games that you want to run.
And then you give it
a list of binaries.
So I'll go into each of
these in more detail.
So the time control is just what
I talked about earlier, which
is if you use Fisher time
control, these are some set,
preset things.
So you would type in one
of the preset things.
So you would talk in blitz to
do 60 and 0.5, for example.
And the number of games is
just whatever you want to do.
And the list of
binaries-- so let's
say you had a
reference invalidation,
and then you made some change.
So I called it
Lesierchess with changes.
And then you would
just put those
after the number of games,
separated by spaces.
And then it would
upload your binaries,
and play them in the
cloud auto tester.
And once you submit your
job, you get a link.
And you follow the
link in your browser.
And you can view
the game running.
And then after the
games are done,
you will get some output saying
like, which bot, one more?
And how many times have
won, and some rankings.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: How fast do they run?
HELEN XU: How fast do they run?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: So it depends on
how many other games are
queued at the same time.
So if a lot of people
are running tests,
it might take some time.
But blitz is just how long
the game itself will take.
And it might take
longer than 60 seconds,
because if you use less than
0.5 seconds in your move,
and then you add 0.5 seconds
at the end of the move,
then you would
increase your time.
But 60 is just the time control.
Each side starts
with 60 seconds.
And depending on how they use
it, they have more or less.
Good question.
Well, I'll keep going.
And if there's time at the end,
I'll do a demo of this one too.
But it basically looks the
same as the scrimmage server.
Like, you just watch the
games in the same way.
So now, I'm going to go into
the project organization, which
is the organization
of the directories
that we handed out in this repo.
So there are some directories.
The first one is doc,
which just includes
the rules and documentation
for the interface.
There's the auto tester, which
is the Java local auto tester.
So if the cloud--
we recommend that you run tests
using the cloud auto tester.
But if there's some small
change, or if you think that--
if the cue is too long,
then you can do local tests.
And you can also
run these overnight.
There's pgnstates, which
just parses your statistics
from the auto test results,
like how many times you won,
stuff like that.
There's tests, which is
how you specify tests.
And I'll go into more detail
about how you define this.
There's the player, which
is where you're actually
going to be optimizing.
So player is the
code that actually
runs the bot to play the game.
And the webgui is a local webgui
where you can watch the game
and play it.
So in the webgui, you can even
play it yourself as a human
so you can get a better
sense of how the game works.
To go into more detail,
the Java local auto tester
is an auto tester.
You can make your changes, and
then you can test your changes.
And the test directory, which is
parallel, holds configurations.
So you can specify the
number of games and the bots
that you want to use,
and the time control,
and other things too.
So this an example
of the configuration
file that you would use
to run your auto tester.
So this is saying that
you run it on 12 CPUs.
And book means that
you're pointing
to open a book, which
I'll talk about later.
Game rounds is how many games
you're going to spawn off.
Title is just the title of
the test that you're running.
And after that, you have
the player definitions.
So player reference
is just the binary.
And invoke is the
path to the binary.
And then fis is
the time control.
And the next one is
just a second binary,
if you made a change and
you want to test them.
Yeah, that's the binary.
To interface with auto
tester, Lesierchess
uses the universal
chest interface, or UCI,
which is a communication
protocol for automatic games.
And you pass information between
the auto tester and your bot.
And it allows the programmer
or the auto tester
to enter moves to
the game engine.
So you could use UCI
to start up your bot.
And then you type in
the moves that you
want to make to see the
changes in the state.
And you could use this to
debug to get to a state
that you want to look at.
We'll measure the bots
using Elo ratings.
So Elo is a rating system
that measures relative skill
level in zero sum games.
The Elo rating depends on the
Elo rating of your opponents.
And on the bottom, you
can see an example output.
So I had three binaries.
And I ran about 100 games.
And you can see that
the Elo of the top one
is much higher than
the other ones.
And so higher Elo is good.
And we'll be comparing
the performance.
We'll be comparing the Elo of
your bot against our reference,
and improved reference
implementations.
So notice that this
is not, as before,
just a straight measure of time.
So like before, in
previous projects,
if you used less time,
than you would get a higher
grade or better performance.
In general, I'll show
you a graph later
that actually shows if
you searched the higher
depth, which means that you
are faster, you do improve.
But it's not an
exact correlation.
And you can look at
the nodes per second
that you search using the UCI.
And just above here, to local
webgui lets you watch a game,
or play one, without sending
it to the scrimmage server.
So if you wanted to
play one as a human,
you would use the local webgui.
And you can run it using
the commands in the readme.
OK, so is everyone good so far?
Now, I'm going to go into more
details about how you actually
play the game.
So first, every
player, or every bot,
needs to generate
the moves, which
means that once you
have a position,
you need to look at the
moves that you can do.
And to do that, you need a
board representation, which
is to represent what
pieces are on the board,
and how big the board is,
and where the pieces are.
And the reference implantation
uses a 16 by 16 board
to store an 8 by 8 board.
So you can see that the inner
squares is actually the board.
And the outer dark
square is sentinels.
So you use sentinels
to keep track
of when you go off the board.
And then the inner square
is just the actual board.
We store the position
using this struct.
So you can see the fields in the
position, which are the board.
And the array size
is just representing
the board, plus the sentinels.
And there's the history
of the position,
which is, how did we get here?
And there's a key, which is
a hash key for this position.
There is ply, which tells
you what side it is.
So even means white.
And odd means black.
There is, what was
the last move that was
made to get to this position?
There's a victim struct,
which is the pieces destroyed
by when you shot the laser.
And there is the
location of the kings.
The position struct
and Lesierchess struct
stores the border
presentation and other things
that I just went through.
So I talked about this move,
which means just like a move
that you make for
one of your pieces.
And I'll go into how
it's represented.
So right now, we already
do the packing for you.
So we use 28 bits.
And the first two
are the piece type.
So there's a number of
moves that you can make.
And the first two bits
represents the piece type,
which is empty, pawn,
king, or invalid.
The orientation of
the piece, which
is just how you rotated it.
The from square, which is where
your piece already started.
There's the intermediate
square, which
is used when you do a swap.
And there's a two square,
which is the final position
that your piece will end up in.
So if you're not doing a swap,
then the intermediate and from
should be the same.
But if you are doing
a swap, then there's
some skipping that happens.
At each turn, you
need to see what
moves you could possibly make.
And in move gen, which is one
of the files in the handout,
we generate all the
moves, given a position,
depending on whose turn it is.
So depending on
whose turn it is,
you can make different moves.
And in the reference
implantation,
we iterate through
the entire board.
And once we find a piece,
we generate all the moves
from that piece.
You can also debug
using move generation.
So there's something
called perft,
which is a debugging
function that enumerates
all moves at a certain depth.
So use perft to make sure that
if you make changes to the move
generation that
you're generating
the same number of moves.
And if you modify
the move generated,
just make sure that
it returns the same,
because regardless
of what optimizations
you do, you still should see the
same moves from each position
that you can possibly make.
OK, so now that we talked
about move generation,
I'll talk about how you
tell that a move is good.
And for that, we use something
called static evaluation.
So we use static
evaluation to determine
which positions are
better than others,
and which moves
that we should make.
And the function eval,
which is in eval.c,
generate a score
based on a position,
using some heuristics.
And at first, we suggest,
instead of making up
your own heuristics,
we suggest focusing
on optimizing the existing
structs and evaluation
heuristics before
coming up with new ones,
because it's kind of hard
to come up with new ones.
And there's a lot
of optimizations
that you can make to
the existing ones.
So I've just grouped
these into categories.
So there's a few
regarding the king.
So there's one
called KFACE, which
is a bonus for your king
facing the enemy king.
There's KAGGRESSIVE,
which gives you
a bonus for if
your King is closer
to the center of the board.
And there's MOBILITY,
which counts up, basically,
how many squares around
your king are free.
You want to be able to
move your king freely.
And there's some
regarding pawns.
So there's PCENTRAL, which gives
you a bonus if your pawns are
in the center of the board.
And there's PBETWEEN, which
basically draw a bounding box
with both kings at the corner.
And then you count
how many pawns
are in the center of those.
And then there's points
based on distance.
So there's LCOVERAGE, which
means laser coverage, which
is basically you make all
the possible moves that you
can make from your position.
And then you draw
the laser path.
And then you do some
scaling to determine
how well you can
possibly cover the board,
based on your current position.
So that's basically how you tell
if a position is good or not,
with these heuristics.
So I'll just go through the
high level of how you actually
play the game using search.
So at the very
highest level, there's
something called game
search trees, which
is we've invented in search.c.
But, basically, this
is a representation
of how you play the game.
At the top, there's
an orange square,
which is the orange side,
which is the opening
position, and then the arrows.
So the top square--
actually, all the nodes
are positions in the tree.
And you use move generation
that I just talked about,
to enumerate all the possible
moves from a single position.
And each edge is a move.
So to get from position
to position, you do moves.
And you can see that
circle is the position
after you've made the move.
And you do this tree
to some depth d.
And then you do static
evaluation of the leaves.
So this is at a really high
level how game playing programs
actually play the game.
They enumerate all
the possible moves.
And then they have a position.
And then they pick which one
is best, based on evaluation.
But you can see that
there's a lot of nodes.
Like, if you do this
naively, there'd
be number of moves raised to
d, which is a huge number,
and too many to generate.
So we're going to talk about
how you reduce those later.
There's something that you have
to do on search series, which
is called Quiescence
search, which
is if you fix your depth--
let's say you fix depth, and
then you go down to the leaves,
and you just captured a piece.
But it's dangerous to just
stop there at fixed depth,
because maybe if you
searched one level deeper,
you would see that the opponent
would capture your piece.
And so if you do
your search, and you
see that you capture
a piece at the leaves,
or your opponent captures the
piece at the leaves, we say,
that's not quiet.
And you keep searching
the tree until there
are no more captures.
So that's called
Quiescence search,
because you quiet the position.
And that's implemented
in the search column.
So this is a graph
that I generated
by doing the reference
spot to different depths.
And you can see that
the Elo increases as you
increase the search depth.
So you just search
the search tree.
And so if you optimize
your bot to make it faster,
you can search deeper, which
means that you'll do better.
So next, I'll talk about
min-max search, which
is a more complex
version of searching
that can improve the amount
of nodes you have to evaluate.
So at a high level, there's
two players, max and min.
And in our example,
there's orange and purple.
And orange is a square.
And purple is a circle.
And the game trees
represents all moves
from the current position from
a given ply, which means depth.
And if the leaves,
like I said, you
play a static
evaluation function.
And max chooses the maximum
score among its children.
And min chooses
the minimum score.
So one side is
trying to maximize,
and one side is
trying to minimize.
To evaluate the
search try, I'll first
talk about an algorithm
called alpha beta, which
is that each search from a
node has a window alpha beta.
And if the value of the
search falls below alpha,
the move is not good enough,
and you keep searching.
And if the value falls
within alpha and beta,
then you increase your alpha,
which is the lower bound,
and you keep searching,
because you know
you can do at least that well.
And if the value of the
search falls above beta,
than you generate a
beta cut off in return.
Beta basically means one
side is trying to maximize,
and one side is
trying to minimize.
So beta is basically
saying, the opponent
would never let you do that
move, because it'd be too good.
So you don't need to keep
searching there, because you're
not going to get there anyway.
So I'll do an example.
Let's say you have this tree.
And if max discovered a
move that min wouldn't
let you do, because
it's too good,
then max's other
children don't need
to be searched, which is
what a beta cut off is.
So you'd start at the root.
And then you go down to
the lowest left leaf.
And you see that it's three.
So you propagate three up.
And then you can see
that in this sub-tree,
you can do at least three.
And then you keep
searching your children.
And then you see six.
And then you say, OK, now
you update your alpha value
to be six.
Now, you search four.
But four is worse than six.
So you don't have
to do anything.
So you first search
the leftmost subtree.
And then you see the best
move that you could possibly
make there.
So you propagate
six up to the root.
And then you search
your other subtrees.
But now, you have
this value of six
that you basically use
in the other subtrees.
So you look at two.
And you see that two
is less than six.
So you propagate it up.
But now, you look at nine.
And you see that nine
is greater than six.
So you say that this subtree
would let purple do nine,
which is greater than six.
And so that would be too good,
because orange would never
let purple do that well.
So you don't have to
evaluate five anymore.
So you cut off five.
Does that make sense?
OK, so, basically, now
you apply the same thing
to the regular subtree.
And you look at seven.
And you see that seven
is greater than six.
So you propagate that up.
And now you're done, because
seven is greater than six.
So you don't have to search
the rest of the subtree.
So that's how you evaluate fewer
moves than the entire tree.
And there's a theorem
that says for a game tree
with branching factor b and
depth d, and alpha beta search
with moves searched
in best-first order
examines exactly b
raised to the d over 2,
plus b raised to the d over
2 minus 1 nodes apply d.
So best first order means that
you sorted the moves in terms
of your static evaluation.
The naive algorithm
examines b to the d nodes.
And in the example I did,
you can see how you prune.
And for the same work, the
search stuff is doubled.
And for the same depth,
the work is square rooted.
So this is a huge benefit
over the naive evaluation.
Is everyone good on alpha beta?
Great, so the code
is pretty short.
So I'll just go through
some pseudocode for it.
Basically, the main
point is that at line 11,
one side is trying to
minimize and one side
is trying to maximize.
But if you negate, then
that's just the same
as minimizing and maximizing.
And you get all
the possible moves
that you could possibly
make using gen moves.
And you go through
the entire move list.
And then you make
each of the children.
And you search for the score.
And then you see whether
you had a beta cut off.
And then you don't need to
search the subtree If you did.
So that was basic alpha beta.
And we actually implement a
variation of alpha beta called
principle variation search.
And the main idea is that you
assume that the first move is
the best one.
And you run scout search, which
is also called zero window
search, on the remaining moves
to verify that they're worse.
So in this example, you,
again, search the most leftmost
subtree.
And you see that the best you
can do in the left-most subtree
is three.
And you evaluate the
ones to the right
of it using scout search,
which is not a full search.
You're basically
assuming that you
can do no better than three.
And then now you're kind of
doing an initial search to see
whether or not that's true.
And see you see that
some of them are--
the one after that is seven.
The first one after
that is seven.
And the one after that in
the other subtree is six.
So then you can prune them,
because those are better--
because you know
already in those
subtrees that you can
do better than three.
So you don't have to
keep evaluating them.
And you don't have to-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do we know
the score of the subtree
before we evaluate?
How can we prune something?
HELEN XU: So you actually
had to find seven.
Like, zero and eight are there.
But you haven't found them yet.
So, basically, if you thought
about doing it serially,
you do the leftmost subtree,
which has 2, 3, and 0.
And then you would find seven.
And that would be a
cut off, because seven
is bigger than three.
So you're not actually
finding zero and eight.
The point is that you
wouldn't get to that subtree,
because the opponent
wouldn't let you get there,
because you can do too well.
So they would just not
let you go down that path.
Like, let's say you were purple,
and the opponent is orange.
And you want to get 7 and 8.
But the opponent can
also search that, and see
that you would get 7 and 8.
So they would prefer you to do
something like two or three.
AUDIENCE: So what
do you do instead?
HELEN XU: You're not always
making the best move that you
could possibly do, because--
like, if you just searched
without this pruning,
and you just picked--
let's say you wanted
to make the best move.
Like, if you don't take
into account the opponent,
then you're never
going to get to there.
So you're basically
trying to find a move
that the opponent
would let you get
to that's also good for
you, because you switch off.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: I guess in this
example, you're purple.
No, sorry, you're orange,
because you're cutting off--
no, you're purple,
because you're
trying to maximize what
you get at the leaves.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: Yes.
The main point of-- sorry.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
We're trying to
minimize the score.
HELEN XU: Yes.
So orange is trying
to minimize the score.
And purple is trying
to maximize the score.
AUDIENCE: So we're
cutting that off,
you're saying you don't need to
search this because we already
know they're the same here.
So we shouldn't go
down this path anyway.
HELEN XU: Does anyone
have questions?
Does that make sense?
Yeah, it's basically
exactly as you said.
So there's kind of this balance
between one side trying--
both sides are just
trying to make--
you're trying to
make good moves.
But you're also trying
to make the opponent make
not good moves, if
that makes sense.
So you're not only
searching for your maximum.
But you're also searching
to minimize the opponent.
Good question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: So we
don't want to choose
either of those orange ones.
We don't want to let--
I think it's OK.
I think you can move on.
HELEN XU: Oh, OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What if
you and your opponent
have different reward criteria?
Like, you guys evaluate--
HELEN XU: That's OK.
It's fine.
The actual evaluation,
like what number
you assign to each position,
is not exposed to the opponent.
The main point is that, at the
end of each move, you pick one.
And they can do with
it what they want.
Like, that may not have
been the one they picked.
But it's OK.
Sorry, I think you're
orange in this one,
because the root is orange.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: So let's start over.
So I think that we are orange.
So remember that
each edge is a move.
And each node is a position.
And so you're orange.
And you start at the root.
And now you, for example,
make the move left.
And purple now can make moves
whatever three after that.
And now, you're orange again.
And then you can make
moves after that.
And now, you evaluate the
position after that as a leaf.
And so, basically,
you're searching
past like the second
level of orange.
And you are cutting off if you
see that you would do better,
because you think that
purple would never
let you get to that
orange node right above.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: Yeah, I guess
that's the score that you,
as orange would receive.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HELEN XU: You're
not trying to give--
it's not so much like you're
trying to give purple zero,
as you think that purple would
not give you seven and eight,
because purple would have
to go down the left subtree
to give you that.
Any other questions?
I'm going to move
on with the search
then, if there are no questions.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
HELEN XU: Is everyone good?
Can I keep going?
OK, so just going back to
principal variations pruning,
the main idea is
that you go down
the first path on the
left side, thinking
that that's the best path.
And then you're basically
doing initial passes
through the trees to make
sure that your assumption is
correct.
And if they're not
correct, then you
have to search the
entire subtree.
But if they are correct,
then you kind of
fail, you early exit.
So you search down
the left subtree.
And you find three in
the leftmost subtree.
And now, you search the
ones to the right of that.
And those are seven and eight.
So those produce a cutoff,
because seven and eight
is higher than three.
So you think that
purple would not
let you get to that subtree.
And now, you do a scout search
again on the middle subtree.
And then you see that--
you find this first node of
each one of those subtrees
underneath the middle subtree.
And you see that they're
all higher than three.
So it turns out that you
failed to prove that you
can do no better than three.
The main point of
the scout search
is that you assume that your
first move that you search
is the best you can do.
And then you do initial passes
to verify that assumption.
And if you search later
subtrees, and you find that--
for example, in this
one in the middle,
they're all higher than threes.
So your assumption is not true.
So now you have to
do a full search
of that entire middle subtree.
Is that OK?
Are there questions?
So once you find that you
have to actually search
the middle subtree, you can
recursively apply scout search.
So you have to search the
left subtree in the middle.
But now, you apply scout
search to the lower middle
and the lower right.
And you do a zero
window search there.
And, again, you assume that
you can do no better than six.
And now, you're trying
to verify that you
can do better than six.
But you actually can.
So you have to search them.
And then you apply the same
thing again to the subtree.
And you see that you
can do better than six
on the left one.
But you do worse than
six on the right one.
And you cut off two, because the
middle subtree already gave you
two.
And so you don't have
to search that one.
So in this example, there
were 13 leaves pruned.
And the point of scout
search is that you
can improve pruning a
little bit over alpha beta,
and that you process
most of the game tree
with zero window searches.
The main point is that it
reduces your work, because you
have to process less.
Questions?
So now we're going to talk
about-- so I kind of glossed
over how you order the moves.
So the ordering
determines which order
you explore the subtrees in.
Alpha-beta search and
principal variation search
depend on putting the
best moves in the front
to trigger an early cut off.
And the main question
is, how do we
determine moves,
which moves are good,
without doing static
evaluation at every level?
Like, for example, we
only did static evaluation
with the leaves.
And we can't get
sortable move list,
which is a function in search.
And sortable move
lists, kind of talk
about how you
populate that later.
As I said before, moves are
represented in 128 bits.
So you can use it in 32.
And to make them sortable,
you store a sort key
in the upper 32 bits in 64.
And then you sort,
based on that key.
That make sense?
So I'll just go over some search
optimizations that you can do.
We actually implement
these already.
So I'm just going
to go through them
so it's not super confusing
when you look at the code.
The most important one is
called the transposition table.
The main idea in the
transposition table
is that chess programs often
encounter the same positions
repeatedly during a search.
And you can store those results
in a transposition table
to avoid unnecessary
feature searches.
And I've listed where
you can find those.
There's something
called Zobrist hashing,
which is a technique for
hashing a board position which
you use to index the
transmission table.
And it's a table of random
numbers, indexed by piece,
orientation, and square.
So each position
has a unique hash.
And it produces the
hash by exporting
all of these random
numbers together.
And the advantage
of Zobrist hashing
is that the hash function can
be updated incrementally, which
is like if you move a
position-- if you move a piece,
you just xor it out.
And then you xor
the new one, so you
don't have to recompute
the hash each time.
So the transposition table
saves you a lot of work
by preventing you from
researching things.
And there's also something
called the killer move table.
So the transposition
table is like how
you determine how to
do sorting at things
that are not the leaves, and
also the killing moves table.
So the killer
moves people stores
moves that are really good so
that the opponent wouldn't let
you go down that path,
so you have to keep
recomputing the same values.
And the table is indexed
by ply, because you
tend to see the same
moves at the same depth.
So the killer move table,
basically, just stores
move that trigger the beta
cut off before in your search.
There's a best move
table, which is stored
at the root of the search.
And it is the move that
got the maximum score
in your evaluation.
And the best move table
is indexed by color,
piece, square, and orientation.
And there's a history
table in the code.
So these are all,
basically, just
things to help you
optimize your search,
and produce early cut offs.
And there's something called
null-move pruning, which
tries to reduce your
search space by first
not moving, and then doing
a shallower search to see
if this subtree is
worth further exploring.
Basically, it says,
don't move, and then do
a little bit of evaluation.
And if you're still
doing really well,
even if you didn't
move in the subtree,
then it's not worth exploring,
because the opponent
would never let you go there,
because the position is
too good.
There's futility
pruning, which explores
moves that only have the
potential to increase alpha.
And it calculates
that possibility
by adding a futility
margin, which
is the most you could possibly
gain from going there, and then
evaluating a little bit.
And if the result does
not go higher than alpha,
then you skip it,
because there's
no point in even going
that way, because it
wouldn't increase your alpha.
There's late move
reduction, which
is after you order the
moves at a position,
you explore the-- the-- ones in
front are likely to be better.
So you explore those
in higher depth.
And then you explore the ones
later with shallower depth,
because those are less
likely to be good.
And some things that
you can optimize
are implementing a
better opening book.
I think we have produced
a very basic opening
book in the handout.
But this is something
that you can definitely
work on, and make better,
because it doesn't have
many positions in it right now.
And the main point
of an opening book
is that you store the positions
at the beginning of the game
that you've already
pre-computed.
And that saves time and
search, and can store results
to a higher depth.
And the KM75 theorem
implies it's better
to keep separate opening books
than to keep the same opening
book for both sides.
So opening books
are really helpful,
because in the beginning,
there's a huge number of moves
that you could possibly make.
And searching those
takes a lot of time.
But if you pre-compute them,
you can save them for later.
And another useful
table you can keep
is an end game
database, which is
a table for guiding your chess
program through the end game.
For end game positions,
the distance from the end
might be too far
to search entirely.
So you can pre-compute them.
And then you store who
will win, and how far you
are from the end of the game.
And we've given you a c file
that you can implement it in.
OK, so I'll just go
through some guidelines,
some tips for the project.
I was giving links
at most of the bottom
of the slides for where you can
read up more on these topics.
But there's a chess
programming wiki.
The link is there, which has
many more pages about reading
about chess playing programs.
Just in general, it's
a really good idea
to test your code
often, because it's
easy to make a mistake
with your optimizations.
And it doesn't appear when
you search to fixed depth.
So if you start up your
bot, you can say, like,
search to depth 5, for example.
And then it will tell you like
how many nodes per seconds
you searched.
And then I'll tell you the best
move at the end of that search.
But you should test
full games using
the auto tester, and
the cloud auto tester,
and the script server,
just to watch your bot
to make sure that it
doesn't do anything weird.
And the testing methodology,
I went through some of it.
There's a webgui.
There's a Java autotester.
There's a cloud autotester.
And you can do node
counts, which is basically
just counting the number
of nodes in the tree
that you searched.
And there's function
comparison testing,
which is, if you
optimize a function,
you should save the
old version, and then
just compare the results.
PROFESSOR: Let me make
a comment about testing.
I can't tell you how
often in this class
we've had student groups
who discover that they've
made a whole bunch of changes.
And then there's something
wrong with their bot.
And they can't get
back to a stable place
when things were correct.
They discover the problem.
But they've made 30 changes.
And now, which of those 30 is
responsible for the problem?
So it's really
important to test,
and have a good
test infrastructure
for this project.
If you have a really
good test infrastructure,
it's really easy to be
innovative in the kinds
of optimizations that
you do, because then you
know that what you're
doing is right.
And then you can make
forward progress.
Otherwise, you'll find yourself
self debugging like crazy,
and not being able
to find the bugs.
Some other tips
are, especially when
we get to the
parallel part, it's
non-deterministic programming.
And the reason is
because as you're
executing you're going
to be looking up things
in transposition table that
you're going to want to share,
so that if one branch
discovers a value then
another branch can use that.
So it's really important
to be able to turn that
off so that you're, for
example, able to search
without a transposition
table to get all
the searching stuff right,
and be able to turn that
on independently.
So that's another really
important place to do it.
Another thing is that when
you do timed searches,
the time it takes to do
the search will vary.
And what you'll end
up exploring varies.
So as much as possible, you
wanted to fix depth searches.
Search to five ply
to test something,
rather than searching
for a minute,
or whatever the
amount of time is,
because when you start
searching for time,
that's, in fact, what you're
going to end up doing.
But you can't repeat what
just happened if you end up
searching for that
amount of time
again, because the machines
are not deterministic.
And there may be
something else going
on that causes the amount
of time to be different.
And so, for example, if
you're making a change that
doesn't affect the
logic of the program,
it's just strictly
an optimization,
you should get exactly
the same result
if you do a five ply
search, for example.
Shouldn't have changed
the five ply search.
Just a five ply search
should be faster.
And so that's a good
way-- as much as possible,
you want to check things that
are deterministic and so forth.
And, really, as I say, I
can't emphasize this enough,
how having a good
test infrastructure,
the ability to control
turn off non-determinism,
the ability to test various
parts of this program,
this is a pretty
big piece of code
for a project of this nature.
And you'll feel pretty
overwhelmed by it
to begin with.
Once you settle,
you'll discover,
it's this wonderful thing,
where by the end of the project
everybody feels really confident
about their ability to handle
a decent sized piece of code.
But when you first get into
it, it's like, oh my goodness.
There's move ordering.
And there's static evaluation.
And there's the search.
And what's going on with
that transposition table?
Because every one of
these things has got
cleverness in it.
OK, so it's really
hard code to deal with.
But you guys are
going to just fine.
HELEN XU: So this is the
eval.c file in the handout.
So this in 32 here is
the evaluation score.
And the main function
is called eval.
And it takes in a position.
And it outputs two scores, one
for white and one for black.
And right now, it does--
I guess it does counts
of the number of pawns.
OK, so I was talking before
about, p between and p central,
which are you pawn heuristics.
And so basically,
right now, it iterates
through the entire board.
You can see for rank and
file are just row and column.
And it looks at each
square in the iteration.
And then it looks at the piece
and the color of the piece.
And based on the type of the
piece, it does some evaluation.
So if it's a pawn, it
does the pawn heuristics.
If it's a fits king, it
does these king heuristics.
And otherwise, or both--
or not otherwise, I guess--
yeah, in both cases it'll do--
this is an old version.
So it's not there anymore.
But this is laser
coverage, which
we talked about
earlier, which doesn't
depend on what piece it is.
This is after you iterate
through the entire board.
And then this isn't
here anymore either.
But we can look at
each of these in depth.
So right now, for
example, there's
p between, which goes
through every single pawn
in your iteration.
And then it will
determine whether or not
it's between both kings,
and the return slide.
So it will add it to the score,
if you find that it's true.
And there's p central, which
takes in a rank and a file.
And, basically, it
increments something,
or it gives you a
bonus, depending
on how close you are to
the center of the board.
So look at this.
There's a board with--
and F as your file.
And R is your rank.
PROFESSOR: I think you have
a slightly older version.
HELEN XU: Potentially.
PROFESSOR: It's
correct on the screen.
HELEN XU: Is
correct in this one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HELEN XU: OK, so
this is just the--
I guess is the most
updated version.
The first one is p central.
So this just count
the difference
between where you are and
the center of the board.
And it gives you some
bonus, depending on how far
you are from the center.
And this one is between.
Yeah, so this is between, which
is a helper for p between.
And it tells you
whether or not your pawn
is in the bounding box
determined by the kings.
And this one is k face,
which is given a king,
you look at its orientation.
And then you give it
a bonus, depending
on which way you're
facing, and how far you
are from the center, I think--
no, how far you are
from the opponent.
So f and r where you are.
And now it does the delta
between you and the opposing
king.
And then you do some scaling,
depending on which direction
you're facing.
So this is just
your orientation.
And then this is k
aggressive, which
gives you a bonus
for how far you
are from the edge of the board.
So you can see here op square is
where do the opposing king is.
And delta file and
delta rank are how far
you are from the opposing king.
And then you add the bonus,
depending on which case
the deltas fall into.
And this gives you a
bonus if you're farther
from the edge of the board.
Yeah, and there's
l coverage, which
is the most complicated
one, probably.
And, basically, what laser
coverage does is that,
basically, it takes a position.
And depending on
what side you are,
it generates all the moves
that you could possibly
make from that position.
So you generate all
with color, which
means that, given
your color, you
generate all the possible
moves that you can make.
And you get a list of moves.
And you iterate through it.
And then you make each of them.
And you draw a laser path.
And what the laser path
does is, basically, it
bounces off some pause.
And for each square, you
increment the distance,
basically, along the path.
And if it takes the
minimum distance
over all these possible
paths for each square.
And if it doesn't touch a
square, then it's just 0.
And it divides it.
I can go into this.
So it draws the path
through this while true.
Or this is just
changing the orientation
if you need to
bounce off a pawn.
But this one is setting the--
you keep a laser map.
And you keep the
minimum path of a laser
that would possibly touch that.
And, no, this is just
changing the orientation.
So then you generate this map
for all the possible moves
that you could do.
And then you do some scaling.
So, depending on the distance
from the opposing king,
you iterate through
the entire board.
And you divide the
minimum distance
by the actual distance
from the laser.
So the maximum that
this ratio can be is 1.
And then you multiply it
by 1 over the distance.
So this one is
really complicated.
And there's a lot
to optimize here.
For example, you
probably don't have
to iterate through
the entire board
each time, because even
in eval, like here, you
have to iterate through
the entire board
to find each piece.
And if you start a
better representation,
you might not have to do
that, like if you just
kept track of where
the pawns were,
because you already keep
track of the king separately.
So that's one thing you can do.
PROFESSOR: There are
two basic strategies
for changing the
representation of the board.
And maybe there are more.
But the two basic
ones are, instead
of keeping the whole board
with a piece on each square,
and then having to go and
search for where the pieces are,
you can keep just a list
of where the pawns are,
and what the locations
of the kings are,
so that when you
want to make a move,
you can just go
through where they are,
rather than having to search
through all 64 squares
on the board.
Then the other strategy
that you can do
is use what's called
bit boards, where
you have a 64-bit word
for which, if there's
a pawn in a given
position, you set that bit.
And so there are different
ways of representing
things that could possibly be,
definitely be, more efficient.
But you have some choices there.
And also, one of the
complexities of this
is that to change
the representation,
there's going to be
places in the code you
need to find out where they're
assuming that things are.
So you say, oh, I'll change
the board representation.
Oh, I didn't realize
that over here, there's
another place that it's using
the board representation,
and so forth.
A good strategy for changing
board representation
is to actually keep both
representations around
while you migrate
functionality from the old one
to the new one.
And then the advantage of
that is that you can actually
then use assertions
to say, you know,
the old one and the
new one are the same.
So implementing conversion
functions is really good.
For example, if
you decide you're
going to use a bit
board representation,
have a function that
converts the bit board
to the standard board
so that then you
can compare whether
you've got the same thing.
And, eventually, you'll
want to get rid of that.
And, of course, that'll
slow down you down,
because you're
doing more things.
But it will allow
you to get it correct
with a new representation.
And once you've got it correct
with a new representation
with the old one gone,
that's when you have a chance
to make things go fast.
But it kind of is taking
two steps backwards
to take five steps forward.
I say not one step and two
steps, because really, often,
you really are slowing things
down considerably in order
to convert from one
representation to another.
The most important thing is
you maintain the invariant
of correctness in your code.
You do not want
to make something
that goes faster, but
is wrong, and have
to debug the correctness.
You'd much rather ensure
that things are correct,
are moving to the place
that you want to do it.
And then you can
optimize for performance.
So the most important
thing is keep
that invariant of correctness.
And that's where
the testing and so
forth comes in, having
good test infrastructure,
and having assertions
littered throughout your code.
HELEN XU: And then we can
go through the [INAUDIBLE]..
Actually, OK, so,
just as an example
of how you would
possibly, one way
of determining whether or
not you state correct--
so this is an example of a
place where I compiled the code.
See the binary code
is called Lesierchess.
And if you look at help,
it gives you some options
for what you can do.
For example, there's display.
And that's the opening position.
And let's say I want to search.
So I do a fixed depth,
and go depth three.
And it tells me
the number of nodes
that I searched at each depth.
And so if you make changes,
if they are deterministic,
these node counts
should stay the same.
So that's one way of telling.
So you should keep
track of this,
and make sure that
they're the same.
And also, you can
do perft, which
gives you the number of
possible moves you can make.
And that should be the
same, no matter what you do.
So that's one way of testing.
There's other ways.
So if you go to higher depth,
you'll get more node counts.
And here, this is nodes that
you searched at this depth.
And this is nodes per second.
So you want to make
this one faster.
So that's how you run the code.
And I was supposed to do a
demo for the auto tester.
So let's say I wanted to do--
so when I made it, it's in
a binary called Lesierchess.
And then here, you
can type in commands.
So you're basically just
typing commands from this.
Like, you run your binary.
PROFESSOR: This is the UCI
interface that we talked about.
And in Lesierchess.c is
the implementation of that.
And so if you want to add your
commands to it to help debug,
you can enter-- if we
go into Lesierchess.c,
you can see the table.
What I want to do
is show the table
of all the options, which is--
there we go, OK.
HELEN XU: This is
just the heuristics.
PROFESSOR: So these are
tables of heuristics
and so forth, which
allow you to set
the values of the
various things,
and to say, how much
is this heuristic
worth to the static evaluation?
And through these,
all these can be
set, so you don't
have to recompile
the binary if you want to try
out things with different--
if you want to
auto test with, let
me count this as worth
a third of a pawn.
Let me count this as worth
half a pawn, or whatever.
You can just enter it
through the UCI interface.
And in the auto tester,
you can specify that.
So it will just test those
without you having to recompile
binaries for every one of them.
And so there's a table
here which basically says,
what's the name
of the heuristic?
What's the variable
that is going to be
set what the default value is?
And pawn ev value is
the value of a pawn.
And if there's any restrictions
on the range of those values,
what's the smallest it can be?
What's the largest it can be?
So you can edit this
table, and so forth.
And as I say, you can set it
through the UCI interface.
So it's really a
very flexible way
of getting access to
anything that you want to do.
You can put your own
commands in there,
including new
heuristics, or whatever.
And there's some
things in there.
For example, if we
go to the other part
where they actually are
passing the UCI stuff,
so it basically takes it.
It parses it, figures out
what the command is, and then
implements the command.
So all that kind of stuff,
you have control over.
So that that will help you in
choosing to do other things.
So, for example, if you
search for perft or something
in there--
so if you have
perft, here's what
the correct outputs should be.
And now, here's the
code that it executes.
And perft is in
a different file.
I think it's in the
move generation file.
HELEN XU: Do I have
the wrong output?
PROFESSOR: That may be
for the older game, yeah.
I actually noticed a couple
of other bugs in there
that hadn't been fixed.
So we will make sure
that those are--
basically, it's just dead
code, is what's in there.
We need to clean up
some of the dead code.
Some of the code
is from last year.
And we changed the game.
And not all the dead
code got eliminated.
HELEN XU: That'll be fixed
for when I make the repost.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So we're just
finishing up some--
right now, I think
it's all cleanliness.
But if you find any bugs
like that, let us know.
We'll fix them, and so forth.
Appreciate if you do see
other inconsistencies,
or what have you.
Good, so great project,
this is like lots of fun.
Next month is going to be
lots of fun for all of you.
You may not think it's fun
every minute of the day.
But you'll have a good time.
It is fun.